ever since the 2018 iPad pro was
released it's been making headlines
because of how much power it's able to
squeeze out of its thin design like for
example it's able to get 120 fps and
fortnight while a lot of high-end
consoles are still limited to 60 I
tested it myself in that video which
we'll link to at the end of this one and
all I could say is that it's so good
that it does give an unfair advantage
compared to other mobile players and now
we're expecting an even more powerful
iPad pro sometime this year in fact
there are rumors pointing to Apple
releasing a brand new 20/20 iPad pro as
early as March so in this video we'll go
through a bunch of leaks and rumors and
discuss when we can realistically expect
a new iPad pro and we'll also talk about
which features it'll most likely be
packing before I get into my personal
reasons for why I think we should expect
the new 20/20 iPad pro and either March
or June let's go through all the rumors
we've received since last year starting
in April 2009 teen with mingsha quo
claiming that the 20/20 iPad pro will
pack a brand new liquid crystal polymer
soft board which will be used to improve
network connection performance and then
in November he claimed that the iPad pro
will come in the first half of 2020 and
pack a brand new time-of-flight 3d
sensing camera system and then in
December he adjusted his report to say
that an iPad pro with an a 14 X chip and
a mini LED display will be released in
the third quarter of 2020 so there's a
chance that we may actually see two
separate iPad pro releases in 2020 with
one packing a brand new mini LED display
and more recently digit times reported
that the iPad pro coming later in the
year could actually support 5g
networking so it would make sense why
Apple would have two releases in one
year in just a couple of days ago didja
times again reported that a new scissor
switch smart keyboard is also coming
this year alongside the 20/20 iPad pro
featuring a backlit design that we
haven't yet seen on the smart Keyboard
so with all those rumours we can almost
surely expect a new iPad pro this year
now let's get into my
for why we should expect the 20/20 iPad
pro and either March or June looking at
Apple's previous iPad pro released
timeline there was exactly 16 months
between the release of the first gen 9.7
inch iPad pro in the second gen models
and then exactly 16 months after that
the 2018 iPad pro was released and you
guessed it 16 months after that release
will be March 2020 so who actually makes
a lot of sense for Apple to release the
20/20 iPad pro at their March event
where they usually release new iPads and
if for some reason they don't release it
then they can release it at their annual
WWDC conference in June which is when
they announced the second gen iPad pro
so based on that if we do truly get a
new iPad pro in March I would recommend
everyone looking to buy an iPad pro to
hold off until then but those of you who
don't want to spend at least $800 on an
iPad should check out our which iPad to
buy video which I'll link to at the end
of this one now let's discuss the
features and specs we can expect to see
on the 20/20 iPad pro first off don't
expect any physical changes since it was
just redesigned with the 2018 model
unless we see a new mini LED display
don't expect any display changes either
Apple is almost certainly keeping
promotion 120 Hertz technology in the
iPad pro which will be difficult to
implement with a mini LED display but if
Apple pulls it off it'll be amazing
we should definitely expect to see
camera improvements possibly an ultra
wide lens on the rear and the new 12
megapixel selfie camera on the front we
should expect the new a 14 X processor
which is got to be the single biggest
change in the new iPad pro even though
the 2018 model was released 10 months
before the iPhone 11 pro it still easily
outperforms it in Geekbench 4s
multi-core CPU tests and then the story
is the same for metal graphics being
around 44% faster than the iPhone 11 Pro
the performance is insane considering
how old the iPad pro is in fact we're
still seeing updates to this day that
are trying to take advantage of it like
fortnight for example enabling insane
120fps mode on the iPad pro and we
expect much of the same thing for the
upcoming a 14x chip there have been
rumors that the iPhones a 14 chip is
switching to a new 5 nanometer process
which will greatly improve performance
and the a 14x should go well beyond that
the main problem we're having right now
is not performance but software and
games being high-end enough to be able
to take advantage of the extra power so
hopefully we should start seeing some
very high end games coming to iOS soon
either way we are extremely excited for
the upcoming 20/20 iPad pro and we're
looking forward to March to see which
Apple products will be released so if
you're not already subscribed do so
right now by clicking the circle above
because we'll have in-depth coverage of
every future Apple product and make sure
to check out the 2018 iPad pro running
fortnight at 120fps right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]